que fait les pommiers merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre le désordre s'est
installé dans le pays
les forces de l'ordre en paye le prix
est l'image de la france à
l'international s'en trouve une fois de
plus affaibli en laissant les casseurs
et les incendiaires s'emparer de la rue
aidé en cela par le laxisme d'une
justice désarmé après le passage de
christiane taubira vous laisser le
pourrissement s'installer au coeur de
nos cités jour après jour la loi n'est
pas muet et les forces de sécurité se
savent condamnés par la faiblesse d'un
gouvernement et l'absence d'autorité au
plus haut sommet de l'état
deux événements d'une gravité extrême
symbolise votre échec tout d'abord à
nantes terrain de jeu de toutes les
violences des as 10 de notre dame des
landes où un crs a été littéralement
lynché
françois hollande est coupable d'avoir
conforté la présence de ces barbares en
refusant d'engager les travaux de
construction du nouvel aéroport
maintenant il s'agit non seulement pour
le président de la république de
condamner ces violences mais également
d'en assumer la responsabilité
ensuite à paris où pour éviter une
tentative d'homicide par incendie un
policier est courageux s'est défendu à
mains nues parce qu'il sait qu en
utilisant son arme il aurait été accablé
par les soi disant bonne conscience de
gauche
dernier soutien de ce gouvernement la
dérive et l'écran est temps de rappeler
à tous ces délinquants avec nos
policiers et nos militaires ont le droit
d'utiliser leur arme de service
quand leur vie est menacée pour que
force reste à la loi
ces derniers jours la situation s'est
considérablement dégradée et le
mitraillage scandaleux d'une permanence
ps en est une illustration
supplémentaire
monsieur le ministre les français n'en
peuvent plus de cette chienlit
allez vous enfin prendre vos
responsabilités en demandant la
dissolution des groupuscules
d'extrême-gauche qui profite de la
faiblesse du président de la république
pour imposer leur violence et l'anarchie
dans les rues de nos villes
la parole est à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le député meunier je pense que
vous êtes dans une situation où l'excès
du ans vous guette
et je voudrais reprendre un à chacun des
propos que vous venez de citer
parce que vous savez j'étais avec les
policiers notamment le policier qui
était dans la voiture extrêmement
courageux et qui par les gestes dont il
a témoigné a fait montre d'une maîtrise
qui faisait honneur à la police et dont
votre discours aurait pu souligner à
quel point il donnait une belle image de
la police de france là où par votre
question vous avez donné une bien
vilaine image de ce qu'est la politique
lorsqu elle dérape et bien les policiers
de france
lorsque je suis à leurs côtés
constamment après qu'ils ont été frappés
voilà ce qu'ils me disent ils me disent
qu'ils sont désolés de voir un certain
nombre d'acteurs de l'opposition dans
l'outrance expliqué que l'autorité de
l'état est remise en cause
alors qu'ils ont perdu 13 mille emplois
que leurs crédits ont été diminués de 10
7% que les brigades anti criminalité et
les psig de france ont été désarmés
faute d'avoir été ré équiper
pendant des années les policiers et les
gendarmes de france me dise monsieur
grenier qui sont particulièrement
sensibles au fait alors qu'ils sont
agressés pour n'est plus interpellé près
de 1500 personnes placées mille
personnes en garde à vue et un certain
nombre en détention notamment les
personnes qui ont agressé les policiers
dans la voiture ce que vous avez oublié
de rappeler oubliant incident rappeler à
quel point la fermeté passe les
policiers et les gendarmes de france
sont capables aussi de savoir comme si
dans une loi présenté par le
gouvernement que des dispositions ont
été mises en oeuvre qui leur permet de
faire face à des tueries de masse
les policiers et les gendarmes de france
sont capables de voir que c'est ce
gouvernement qui commercer
les anciens du gouvernement que vous
avez souscrit
merci qui voulaient bien un soir et je
donne la parole